a minute that I landed on set It was as
if I'd been gone for like a day
ultimately it's just it's feels like
coming home it's been great I always
have time for an old friend
yeah after a year of will he or won't he
Patrick's back for the ninth and final
season of suits this character Mike Ross
returns to the legal drama during
episode 5 without his wife Rachel
aka Dutchess Megan Markel for Mike this
is just a trip to New York you know
there's phone calls with Rachel and
saying goodbye and I love you and you
know I think there's some obviously
acknowledgement that she's still there
and a part of the show and this is just
a way for him to come and see his
friends one last time so no we won't see
Megan but the new mom is still on the
minor for old cast mates especially
Patrick who also just welcomed his first
trial wife Troian Bellisario was
actually pregnant with their daughter at
the royal wedding tell me you tell me I
don't know the match me it sounds like a
pretty crazy world
I wish Megan all the best I'm really
happy for them you're gonna make me cry
I'm just getting started
while this cast is preparing for their
final goodbyes there is a silver lining
for fans a new spinoff Pearson with past
suit star Gina Torres so will we see any
familiar faces it would absolutely make
sense for any one of these characters to
show up especially Donna Katrina is
available for hire and so is Amanda call
me just look at Sodor - nothing crazy
but you know maybe samantha comes in and
helps her with something
maybe it would just be like you know one
or two scenes where jessica gives her
some fashion advice you know like this
is how you should be dressing
[Music]